what to you as a difference because
youve had a bit of foot in both uh
between physics and Mathematics in the
way it helps us understand the world
well there's to be frank there's a lot
more overlap in physics and math I think
than has been I mean well maybe not more
but there's certainly a lot but I think
again the kinds of questions you're
asking are usually different um
mathematicians like the structure itself
physicists are trying to concentrate on
to some extent on the consequences for
the world um but there is a lot of
overlap the string theory is an example
there's certain theories where there's a
a certain kind of mathematical Beauty to
it there's also you know there's also
some really cool ideas that you get in
particle physics where you can describe
what's going on and connected to other
ideas that's also really beautiful um
you know I think I think basically
insights can be beautiful um you know
they might seem simple but sometime and
sometimes they genuinely are and
sometimes they're built on a whole
system that you have to understand
before I mean if you actually saw
Einstein's equations written out in
components he wouldn't think it's so
beautiful you write in a compact way it
looks nice uh what do you think about
the successes and the failures of
strength Theory to what degree do you
think it's succeeded to what degree is
it not succeeded yet or has failed I
think to talk about any science in terms
of success and failure often misses the
point because there's some absolute
thing and I think I do think that
strength theists were a bit overly
ambitious not overly ambitious but a
little bit overly arrogant in the
beginning thinking they could solve many
problems that they weren't going to
solve that's not to say the methods and
um advances and strength Theory don't
exist and um but they certainly weren't
able to immediately solve all the
problems they thought they could solve
but it has given us tools it has given
us some
insights um but it becomes almost a
sociological question of like how much
it should be one or the other I do think
that you can get caught up in the
problems themselves and and sometimes
you can get caught up in the methods and
just sort of do other examples so the
real physics insights often come from
people who are thinking about physics as
well as as
math